si votre partenaire vous propose de
faire l'amour à trois
vous préférez un homme ou une femme
Taure rose
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
alors non je m'attends à tout là
faire qualifie et tout ça donc j'ai dit
le prochain beau garçon qui arrive dans
l'émission j'ai fait l'interview alerte
rose
depuis tout à l'heure Jamel fait
insulter je dis rien que physiquement je
suis comment Lolita
alerte rose
finalement ce manteau rouge au début
tout le monde c'est foutu de sa gueule
au début de l'émission finalement ça
peut aider ouais peut-être ça peut
rendre service
pas trop mais je vais essayer est-ce que
vous préféreriez faire l'amour avec
mille femmes toujours de la même façon
ou toujours avec la même femme de mille
façons différentes
la même femme de mille façons
différentes
façons différentes parce que moi je
connais plein de techniques
est-ce que vous préfériez faire l'amour
avec une femme unie d'un sexe d'homme ou
avec un homme muni d'un sexe de femme ah
c'est des nouvelles questions elles sont
encore pire qu'avant une femme je
l'encule
sacrée vide
voilà Astrid toujours intéressé
déjà
c'est terrible qui cherche à me caser
oui oui
propose de faire l'amour à trois
vous préférez un homme ou une femme
ah une femme une femme pourquoi je
réfléchis
dites-moi ça c'est très important et
Astrid et très attentif vous préférez
faire l'amour ou baiser faire l'amour
parce qu'on peut faire l'amour et ça se
transforme en baise d'accord alors que
baiser
c'est incroyable
non mais moi je préfère de manière
générale
c'est important dans la vie c'est super
important
c'est la vie ça tiens justement voilà
une autre que si c'est la vraie vie ça
pourrait faire auriez que votre campagne
vous quitte pour un homme ou pour une
femme
pour une femme parce que je pense
qu'elle va se laisser un moment elle
revient
alors vous préférez regarder votre
campagne faire l'amour avec un autre ou
faire l'amour avec une autre pendant
qu'elle vous regarde avec une autre
pendant qu'il y ait rien vous préfériez
coucher avec une fille gonflable ou une
fille gonflante
c'est pas très à la mode
vous préférez une femme qu'on prend sans
la comprendre ou une femme qu'on
comprend sans la prendre
[__] tu dis que c'est des conneries
mes questions
qu'on comprend sans la prendre on
comprend sans la comprendre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu